ma da volessero audiences bene ho visti
allo yen ed ho mangiato rom ma non so se
basta io ho preso un altro il tuo amico
sebastian il registro di conchiglie
mentre a fuoco i tuoi piatti parlanti
nella lavastoviglie io mangimi amici a
su ok ma tu hai un armadio che
assomiglia moira orfei due tre sorelle e
vestite tutte a te ma tu sei la più
piccina ai 15 anni appena acqua sembrino
resta attinà lana della mancavi solo te
l'hanno chiamato a sé ma invece ti ho
vista l'altra sera dopo un bicchiere di
troppo parlare con la teiera mentre io
canto in fondo al mare in un alcolizzato
e cattivi in fondo al bar
l'atroce ma non ti avevano rubato la
voce preti più di un testimone di geova
ho visto la tua
l'acquario di genova principessa se così
cessa che tra la bella e la bestia tu
sei la bestia parli di me ma non hai
capito
ti faccia più belle di tuo marito
non è tra i due sono la bestia ma parli
te che si pettini con la forchetta io ti
regalo un paio di scarpe vero così la
smetti di girare col sacco a pelo
2 la bestia siete proprio carini ma cena
gli e rilanci croccantini e quando forti
costi bambini a scuola sono piccole
vecchi e gli metti la museruola
bella ragazza ti è piaciuto il video
mette the like alla pagina mi trovate
anche su instagram marina official giu
ammazza 7 buona reparto